all right last time on 113 questions
about evolution we talked about the
physics i guess you could say the
embryological development
of the flat face trait why is it what
happens during embryology that ends up
producing the flat face
in pug dogs and a variety of other
flat-faced dogs
just a refresher because it's been a
while since i made that video
dogs that have normal wolf shaped faces
you know the long straight snouts
that happens because the top of the
snout grows at the same rate
as the bottom of the snout flat-faced
dogs like pugs
the top grows really slow and the bottom
grows really fast which causes them to
curl upward and then in dogs like the
bull terrier with faces that slope
downwards
that occurs because the top grows faster
than the bottom
so that's what we learned last time and
we use the the frosting examples right
to kind of get a feel for how that works
at a
physical level when the embryo is
developing why it is that those weird
shapes
end up occurring but today we are going
to talk about the genes
that encode for those changes in
physical form
between different dog breeds which
mutations in which
genes cause flat faces and pugs
and the droopy faces in bull terriers
113 questions about evolution
with john perry evolutionary question
number 14
what specific mutations give pugs
their flat noses the development of
plants and animals from
embryo to full adult is an extremely
extremely complicated process and
scientists
are trying to figure out how it is that
different genes and different mutations
in those genes
give rise to phenotype so the actual
shape
of an adult we're actually not very good
at being able to figure this out it's so
complicated there are so many different
chemical reactions involved
so many different signaling pathways
that are involved genes in the
environment they play off of each other
it's an absolute mess to try and figure
out how this stuff works but
scientists are doing it and they're
doing so in several different ways
one way is that you can actually turn
genes off and learn what what it was
that those genes were doing before you
turn them off by seeing
how an embryo breaks when it's trying to
develop
and we do that a lot with zebrafish and
with mice and so on
and the molecule that's used for that is
normally morpholinos
stretches of artificial rna that can
actually turn
genes off if you know the sequence of a
gene you can order a morpholino with
the anti-sequence to that gene and it
will silence that gene
and then another way to figure out what
different mutations do
how they affect an organism is to just
look at a bunch of different organisms
that have different traits you know
close relatives that have slightly
different traits or dramatically
different traits and then you look
at their genomes you sequence their
genomes you look for differences and you
correlate those differences
in genotype with differences in
phenotype
again genotype is the sequence of dna
or rna if it's like a virus or something
genotype is the sequence
of dna that an organism has the
phenotype
is the the structure of an organism once
it's developed
the really cool thing about dogs is that
there are so many different types of
breeds and they have so many different
traits
that you can actually just study
different dog breeds compare their
genomes with the genomes of other dog
breeds
and you can start to get a picture of
what mutations are causing their unique
traits
and to do this properly and to really
figure out the actual
you know causation instead of just some
random correlation
you know correlation isn't always
causation right to do this well you need
to look at lots of different dog breeds
try and follow single traits you know
there are lots of dogs that have flat
faces
there's pugs of course but there's also
boston terriers and
french bulldogs the skull that i have
this actually comes from a french
bulldog
and yeah very flat face and then also
you know
there's like the apple headed chihuahua
also has a flat face
i actually got one of their skulls
around here somewhere
this right here that is a
an apple-headed chihuahua with the flat
face
trait bred into it and i mean just look
at this
so here's a wolf here's a chihuahua
for comparison chihuahuas evolved from
wolves
so that is insane
that is just crazy that this came from
this
sure enough it did so over the years
lots of scientists have worked on these
comparative anatomy studies along with
these comparative genetic studies
and they've really done a good job
teasing out the actual mutations
that are causing these differences in
phenotype and there's a lot of work to
be done still but
we've got an amazing start just through
comparative anatomy and comparative
genomics one of the genes that we've
found that's really important
for the shape of the snout is one called
run
x2 and we found that within this gene
the run x2 gene
there are two sections that consist of
tandem repeats
these are sections of dna that just
repeat in sequence over and over and
over again
one of them is labeled q the other is
labeled a
and these labels were chosen because of
the specific amino acids that these
tandem repeats code for so this is a
protein coding gene
that has two different tandem repeats
within it
tandem repeats are really interesting
chunks of dna
because they can go through what are
called slipped
strand mispairing this is a very special
type of mutation
where the enzymes that copy dna when a
cell is reproducing or when sperm and
egg are being produced
those enzymes they'll attach to this
stretch of dna they'll start trying to
make a copy of it
and they can slip they can get bumped
off in that process and when they
reattach
they can reattach in the wrong spot i'm
kind of oversimplifying things a bit
here but
what ends up happening is sometimes they
can copy a chunk that's already been
copied and they make a strand of dna
that's too long
in other cases a slip strand mispairing
can cause a chunk of dna to be skipped
when being copied so it can make the
gene shorter than normal
these types of mutations are extremely
common when you have
a stretch of dna with tandem repeats
in its sequence what scientists found in
this 2004 paper called
molecular origins a rapid and continuous
morphological evolution what they found
is that any mutation that increases the
length of
q segment q in this gene relative
to segment a this causes the top of the
snout to grow
faster than normal in other words this
is exactly what we see
in the bull terrier because the top of
the snout is growing faster
than the bottom of the snout and check
this out
they actually found that bull terriers
have an extremely long q compared to a
segment in this gene and the run x2 gene
and
they went kind of back in time if you
look at photos of old
bull terriers you know if you go back
100 years or so
you'll see that they still have the
droopy face but it's not nearly as
extreme
and they actually found tissue preserved
from one of these old dogs with kind of
the intermediate version
of this trait and they sequence its
genome and sure enough
there was an intermediate version of
this gene here the ron x2 gene the
q was slightly longer than a but not
extremely longer as we find in modern
bull terriers this was a really cool
confirmation of this finding that
yeah this mutation the lengthening of
segment
q compared to segment a really does seem
to be what's causing
the fast growth on the top of the snout
versus the slow growth
on the bottom of the snout now as you
might expect the reverse
is also true if mutations lengthen the a
segment in relation to the q segment
the top of the snout will grow slower
than the bottom of the snout
and as a result the face will curl
upwards
now this mutation alone cannot explain
the extremely flat noses that we find in
pugs
you actually need more mutations in
order for that to happen
but it can explain the kind of you know
mildly flat
faces and upward pointing faces that we
find in like
great danes so these two stretches of
dna within
the run x2 gene they kind of act like
little dials
different mutations over time can dial
the face to be
stubbier and point more upward or dial
it to be longer and point more downward
and it's a really cool control mechanism
that happens here and these mutations
they happen very easily and we've seen
again
with the bull terrier that these
mutations are happening still today this
isn't something that
you know happened a long time ago in
wolves and selective breeders just
pulled it out of the original wolf
population
these mutations are still happening now
and they're still changing the shapes
of dog faces mutations like this are
just a continual source
of novelty that evolution can play with
or in the case of dog breeding
dog breeders can play with a second
paper that was published in 2012
they found that there are five more
stretches of dna within the dog genome
that appear to influence the length and
shape
of the snout there are probably lots
more but we know of five of them they
were able to pinpoint one of them really
specifically
they discovered a single point mutation
in the gene called
bmp3 and this point mutation
dramatically flattens the face
it's found in pretty much all the small
breed dogs that have flat faces it's not
found in the larger dogs like the boxers
that have
moderately flat faces but it is found in
things like boston terriers and
french bulldogs and wait for it the pug
so now we have two independent mutations
that both
affect the flatness of the nose and if
you add those two together you get
more extreme flatness if you have just
one you get
fairly mild flatness but then another
paper in 2017
found yet another really important
mutation in our genomes and in the
genomes of dogs
there is a gene called smoc2 smock2
in flat-faced dogs this gene contains a
large insertion a retrotransposon
has been inserted into an intron in this
gene so an intron is a part of a gene
that's not normally
coded into protein it's just sitting
there in the middle and a
retrotransposon has been inserted in
there
retrotransposons for those who don't
know are chunks of dna that are able to
make copies of themselves and do sort of
a copy-paste
mechanism throughout the genome of an
organism so they code for a protein
that then makes a copy of that gene and
inserts it into other chunks of an
organism's
genome and a lot of these come from
viruses so this retrotransposon has been
inserted into the middle of an intron in
the middle of the
smock 2 gene several really careful
experiments show that this
insertion slows the expression of the
smok
2 gene it makes it so that during
embryological development
less of the protein coded for by this
gene is produced
and as an end result you get really flat
faces
this mutation alone was responsible for
more flatness
in the face and any other mutation we
found so far
if it is the only mutation that's
inherited and this we were able to
figure out by studying different cross
breeds if a crossbreed has
this mutation and not the other two
mutations
it still has a pretty dang flat face
it's not as flat as if it has all three
of these things these mutations work
in kind of an additive manner but with
this mutation alone they have a very
very flat face so let me just kind of
put this all into perspective here
we have discovered we scientists have
discovered there are three
different types of mutations that can
cause
a flat nose to occur in dogs we've got a
slippage mutation
we've got a point mutation and we have a
an insertion mutation these three very
very different types of mutations
completely different origins
they all work together to cause this
flat face trait
in pugs you might think that uh that's
not cool
uh for those who know a lot about these
flat-faced dogs
they have a lot of health problems
because of these mutations
that said there is something about
flat-faced dogs
that really seems to trigger people's
parental instincts
doesn't doesn't do this for all people
but for some people they just
they melt when they see one of these
flat-faced dogs
i just find this absolutely absolutely
fascinating
that the messy way in which new traits
arise
next question